[Music]
you know I'm not saying
it's [__] tonight they drinking it
[Music]
and we are [__] Tuesday night if
you're watching The Bachelorette put it
on hold
it's uncle Joey and the [__]
coming your way [__]
[Music]
there you go if you're under 18 and up
now [__] up this cuz it ain't gonna get
no pretty oh [__] we're hitting it from
all angles tonight [__] we got
the magic joint with the hash
[Music]
is it safe I have no idea who soon find
out you dare enter this house
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoo it's a hot one clean that way
[__] and elbows gotta be stinking up
a [__] storm
[Music]
you still got the commie killer here
it's marinated in a marinade of the
juices oh that you can't even [__]
describe understand
[Music]
happy birthday to me [__] you
guys that want a dad this is it this is
the new invention from Joey Diaz like a
doctor [__] look at it I'm like
Frankenstein running down the street and
[__] we ain't [__] around tonight we
got the goods we got the the kamikaze
bud dipped in [__] heroin oils this
is direct from [__] Isis right here
we got everything tonight we got [__]
buds of debt you understand me
we got [__] that would kill the common
[__] man
but hey you're here and that's all that
matters
look at this the earthquake relief back
which side of this to houston does
that's what they need some of this [__]
right here check this thing we'll be
floating downriver just grab it like a
dumpy [__] my heart goes out to houston
i donated today in the name of the
church and also we're gonna put together
some benefits for you [__] so
Euston was Betty Betty Betty Betty good
to me back in the day and I don't forget
nothing that's what [__] makes you a
savage besides that we're back it's a
fun-filled week I hope you enjoyed Rudy
Sarzo but it's the Olympics of reefer
here tonight [__]
[Music]
you're like Joey what the [__] are you
smoking it's not what we're smoking if
what it's what ain't we smoking tonight
we got stars purple and red ones we got
acid we got everything you understand me
everything you need to get the party
started right and that's the most
important thing if you throw a bad party
nobody want to hang out with you you
understand me you got to throw good
parties you gotta have plenty of water
you have ice cubes to rub on your face
in case somebody passes out and you
gotta have the right reefer and the
right combination of people that's a
party you follow me not hanging out with
a bunch of [__] with hats on telling
you about their thoughts of economical
change in the atmosphere suck my dick
[__] take that fake lingo somebody else
somewhere else like a Starbucks
somewhere is something you can talk
about that [__] and make-believe people
give a [__] yeah I'm saying cuz here in
the church what's happened now we don't
give a [__] you understand me we're
dropping facts about life which is
what's important you trying to change
the economical social justice of the
weather you can suck my dick meanwhile
your wife is blowing some other guy
while you're [__] thinking about the
social economic change your [__]
weathers and [__] this uncle Joey [__]
with [__] Lisa at the original
[__]
ready to smoke some [__] death you
understand me we're gonna sprinkle this
on top of that and there you go my
friend salud no it's for the guy next to
you yes for you you [__] for me
what's the breathing technique no feel
that belly button going into your spine
there you go that's right there you go
better look at me smoking and [__] Elvis
didn't even look this good yet I'm
saying anyway
when you're down that's the [__] that's
the [__] that's the Mack let's go Mack
right there that's the Mac Lisa yeah
that's the Mack give you a new PC wanna
set you up nice [__] up yeah I'm
saying that pipe is on fire this [__]
for you people on Joey don't dad go [__]
yourself
I just lit the [__] barn on fire
that's a real dab you [__]
anyway it's a beautiful week to be alive
Labor Day you're gonna see your [__]
family put away the white shoes you know
all that [__] [__] what aslha here at
the church we're gonna do what we always
do have a good time smoke reefer and
look for the devil he's making a
comeback
[Music]
oh [__] that bond is still kicking like
a mule but I gotta clean it out for my
manly
I got a dip in ice water or something
cuz this [__] on fire this
briefing right here this is three
combinations of four different weeds
that would [__] him
bring Hitler back from the grave that's
how strong this [__] is right near we're
saving this for the earthquake or the
flood I got it in double baggies with
[__] little rubber tires on it so to
float him saying you don't [__] around
here anyway
put that page that [__] I tell
them to turn up the air it's hot in here
oh yeah yeah yeah it's still [__] hot
that's what we can't have no podcast in
the daytime we're gonna have my boobs
supposed to have my man Luis Gomez on
yes the kymaro before that it's too
[__] hot it's 108 on this
[__] Valley and people were
walking around I seen some idiot with a
[__] skateboard with a phone
1:08 I wanted to hit him with the car
just out of principle that guy have a
little decency left here I'm saying but
anyway enough with the chitty-chat of
Joey it's time for the [__] bong gets
a dead let time their lights are going
out oh [__]
[Music]
be more [__] still crying about the
Mayweather fight
listen knock it off get it together
it's all over get a life I'm saying it's
time to get a life go get a girlfriend
or something well who gives a [__]
it was three days ago go get a [__]
life don't worry about nothing don't
worry about kana don'twe by bond away by
Mayweather they're all doing fine at
home counting 20s and you're still
[__] arguing like a Mook who gives a
[__]
worry about yourself and what's in front
of you I'm saying and that's it and
that's that it's time for another bulb
do you agree or what do you want do you
wanna come over here and sit there not
smoke why and I work for UPS I don't
give a [__] it's time to put that
[__] piss test to the task jack and
make sure that [__] those tests are
working half these people got you on the
[__] scared routine and ain't even
testing you piss did you know that
there's something I found out recently I
know a lot of people ask questions
you're following me anyway I hope you
guys are gonna have a great week after
Wednesday everybody's [__] brain dead
anyway thinking about this and thinking
about that and what they're gonna do on
their [__] day off me I don't give a
[__] you understand me
every day is the same 24/7 swinging dick
taking names and going for broke but
most importantly being a little better
than the day before
that's it that's all you want to do you
ain't no [__] swing a little roof I'm
saying you're just trying to be a little
better than what you were yesterday Adam
ray in the house the christ-killers in
the house Lisa I yet what's going on I
got a [__] bong ready for you this
belief is he was [__] around he's
[__] around I'm saying I'm gonna load
him a [__] a Puerto Rican hamburger I
haven't made one of these in [__]
years if I had some ass I put it in
there too like three layers yeah like
jello from the old days I'm in the old
days they had jello that was like
chocolate white chocolate and white
shook on the bottom
making layers okay so you tipped into
class in the wait that's the 70s they
don't do that [__] like what
that [__] was telling [__] on
that so you take a class and you fill up
halfway you took the class the
refrigerator and the jello would come
and it would dissolve itself and it'd be
like a Neapolitan ice cream yeah I was a
chubby kid now I'm doing it with drugs
see with Nabisco [__] patented I
[__] took it for the next one and
then we got some of this [__] here look
at this atom right this is like a nugget
of weed that I put in front of the
heater and it [__] look at this
[__] weed look at this [__]
oh this looks like a burnt victims
[__] toenail I don't give a [__] this
is it this is it right here we got
everything with a 21st birthday party in
Seattle yeah we put it down and Josh
wolf Club have a [__] a Lobo Loco
what are you nuts I was trying to find
the clip last night you ready breathing
exercises look back like a breathing
exercise and look back
let the blood go to the back of your
brain think about what you're about to
do the buying it is all about technique
ready let's do this [__] suck it like
it's a [__] it's the last dick on
earth go go hit that hit that savage all
the way like a [__] there you go
there you go there you go that's for
you can't kill them grace they're gay
you can't kill women grace that game
they even making a [__] come back now
what we gotten him bleep hey you go well
we search in searching for that feeling
and easy come and easy go
oh [__] Louise Kingsley Oh feel like
[__] look at that I quote it down here
something oh yeah little only they've
been baking in the other yeah
mmm-hmm don't even think about Adam ray
you end up like [__] Linda Lee on the
couch laying there telling me that
[__] Cosby finger-banged you are you
asleep in it I'm saying that's what
could happen somebody come here do it
edible lay down on the couch and it's a
[__] somebody finger bang and then me
only go to jail with dirty fingernails
and iam say it's a [__] nightmare
[Music]
and we got this atom ready to get the
party started for you this is 2 grams of
wheat with a grandma hash they tie it
with a [__] and then quality some
Mexican name to the doodle dozen the
Mexican
[Music]
your bling gonna be the weed that will
[__] the smoke in here you understand me
I got this hurricane relief we right
here
you said this is hurricane earthquake
relief this stays in the office a lot of
times in the [__] safe with the two
grams H and everything else they got
ready for [__] disasters here people
gonna need [__] vicodins whenever
there's an earthquake and here we are
selling Vikings at $22 per
[Music]
Eagleman you start with that ready for
another bog in yellow bleep Tanya this
is the [__] we're going deeper than deep
tonight we [__] around we'll bring it
on the heartache tonight
[Music]
oh [__]
you know what that bong it was called
smooth [__] it's a very nice and
tight when you smoke some marijuana is
smooth you ready Adam hit that [__]
mule when I [__] around tonight I
told you go raid your grandfather's
[__] medicine cabinet there's got to
be something in there chemo tablets
something that a couple shots of whiskey
and there you are
dare you walk [__] I having a good
old time
which uncle Joey chemo tablets raving me
chemo I have no [__] idea
oh yeah we're going for broke tonight in
the smoke and you in the mood to smoke
reefer tonight's your lucky [__]
night okay tonight's a night away you
know stories that I don't want to hear
that your pussy's hurting and your
[__] got bang too hard over the
weekend I got another do it uncle Joey
all I have to do is make sure you see
the devil and get prepared for the week
ahead
if not just tomorrow cuz listen Thursday
don't matter
tomorrow's the day you wake up you shoot
out the box like a [__] meth addict
and you're ready to [__] go how would
you if you want man that would you leave
the house like a savage but you're not I
met you sit there all day playing
[__] video games and you wonder why
the walls are caving in then you gotta
get out there you gotta get some vitamin
D you gotta breathe you gotta interact
with people I've been talking to a black
homeless do lately he's become my best
friend a salad he stinks like ten dead
pieces of [__] but I gave him a 20-year
- song by 7-eleven every time I see him
I took him with a [__] 20 and I got a
friend now you follow him or that
[__] is an ex-football player he
said you see a black dude with the thick
drag that dudes a big [__] I
became friends with
look acknowledged like 32 he's [__]
crazy but the one day my wife and my
daughter cross the street that was my
car and he stopped the car for them so I
didn't see him that day so I wanted to
do come under 20 he's little homeless
he's little pots but he still has a lot
of life left in his eyes and that's all
that matters to me I don't come to know
these homeless kind of suckers over here
several let me they're just a bunch of
young kids looking for a [__] hand
I'm one robbed people like I did at my
age but there's people were seriously
being [__] help
and I do come when I say him out of
respect whether they ask or not I give
him a little Duke why because now is
down people used to dupe me without
asking you don't have to ask when you
need a [__] Duke it's your body
language is for look on your face and
you don't want to embarrass nobody it's
honestly not the front make a big show
like an [__] just slip in his hand
get my hug he won't even know just what
it's his lucky day
and you made somebody's day Joey what's
with the [__] ear beat what are you a
[__] fortune cookie let's smoke some
[__] pop concert
[Music]
that's what we're talking about right
there when you blowing those type of
clouds you come see Uncle Joe and don't
show up with a [__] fake baggy vapor
pen cuz I'll smack him throw you off the
[__] balcony waiting that time for
fake [__] break the pens maybe have a
smoke vapor pen take a chance smoke the
cigarette get cancer nut go dick around
with these people alright look at me man
like a [__] Mook the Mook anyway oh
my gosh which the album I'm gonna put on
my favorite cut from this out 1981 def
Lepp it's high and dry their second
release one of the album's that put me
over the top sometimes somebody calls
your mother a [__] fat [__] sometimes
some of these tabs your sister some
sometimes somebody kicks your dog it
sets you over the top this album set me
over the [__] top many a night i sat
there depressed
snorting coke drinking thinking about
[__] taking us one dive but this
album saved me you follow me don't go
away
it's not
[Music]
we're doing other piece of us it's not
Adam right just mean who gives a [__]
it's how I wanted this or you at some
point it's it's a Hanukkah [__] week
um say listen we make all the rules here
at the church we decide the Catholic
holidays Muslim holidays they do Ramadan
one couple weeks ago we do Ramadan in
January when you need to lose weight
your fake food I'm saying why do Ramadan
in September when shits crack-a-lackin'
people having barbecues is [__] if you
don't do Ramadan let's do in January
when everybody needs to drop 10 pounds
I'm looking forward not to eat no
[__] day I'm saying so now on the
church what's happening now Ramadan
whatever is in January
[__] Hanukkah starts right now for
the Jews if you're a Jew right now this
time after Labor Day
that's when Jews gear up Juke like Floyd
Mayweather he get up in the 6th round
that's when Jews come to life just when
you take you ganas down
you got that eviction notice we pop out
with some [__] Jew from Israel that
knows laws you never even [__] heard
of [__] he was George Washington's
second cousin through marriage but
George can tell nobody was married to a
Jew in 1776 I didn't like that [__] I'm
saying you can bang the muli but did you
stop it you following me anyway the
point is what I don't even know what the
[__] point is I'm stone for the gills
let me get some purple stars Lee you're
making me stretch I'm another [__]
thing let's do this [__] [__]
Hanukkah starts today and we've one star
every [__] day Hanukkah December 29th
two days before Ramadan don't like that
everybody gets their [__] [__] sure
why not
who gives a phone make the gloss for
years you've been listening to some
[__] book [__] them what Megan on
religion I'm like I turn in 84 I'm
writing my own books I'm making my own
stories oh my god
these things are [__] gooood nice and
right the TAC is on fire in here
it's like finger the fact I could fall
on the board in this bag you don't say
look at this it's a finger and a fat
chicken for you give me that [__]
thing and you can feel [__] gummy
bears in there and [__] peanut
brittle and God knows what else
oh my god these things like Hey look at
how they live that's how we do it
tonight so Ramadan anyway let's not
worry about Ramadan let's worry about
[__] Annika and then next week on
thing Tuesday is a big Cuban [__] huh
I gotta stay in Tuesday night gotta be
on by midnight
it's a big Cuban holiday Tuesday and
Wednesday I gotta stay in at night
lights and candles [__] kill a couple
chickens and then then I'm free to like
November and then I got to start my
Santeria [__] heavy December 4th we'll
mix that with [__] the end the
Chanukah it's a party [__] you
understand me
this is a party I don't give a [__] what
you think it's a one-man party tonight
Adam Ray's showing up my main Christ
kill at least I got showing up I want to
show the world how it's [__] dumb
either you're in or you're out you
looking for me gonna join when he planes
next I have no [__] idea and I don't
give a [__] I think it's like September
9th working out with Uncle Joe at the
ice house but listen I'm only worried
about the 29th august cuz that's how we
roll Tellem Adam great-looking school
29th august baby come on come on
he's been sending out resumes for a
month our zipper occurred nobody's even
considered Coleman I know every day they
eat more sauce every day said Seiko and
what is zipper crew they're gonna get me
a [__] job it's pretty nice the
finger affection from time to time like
a three finger movie you got in there
that [__] opens up
you smell that banging OH
listen whatever the [__] you want to do
tonight Duke but I wouldn't [__] stay
off this channel and we got a great show
my little brother mr. raised here
tonight International [__] movie star
let me tell you something 1984 atom rain
it was a look-alike theater he look just
like you he was [__] beautiful
he was on an episode of Miami Vice that
pee-wee Herman was supposed to be it but
three weeks before the episode shot
pee-wee Herman that quite jerking off in
a movie theater so he was replaced by a
comedian and last and I began I've met
that comedian I was intrigued by him
I've been doing comment like for years
and I asked him a bunch of that episode
those questioned him he stolen he stole
he killed that episode this comic but
the main drug dealer that episode you
could have been his son like you could
be inside and he wore suits and he had a
wig body ha si si no Miami Vice way
before you were born May 24 when were
you born
yeah you were three when that
[__] head your parents put you
to bed snort some coke and watch Miami
Vice my parents [__] thing put that
little [__] to bed nine o'clock
eight o'clock no nine o'clock was crime
story no neither classes Miami Vice yeah
it's an o'clock was crime story on a
Friday night so that means you did not
go out people would call you I'm picking
you up at 8:00 I don't give a [__]
Miami Vice is on at night
the coat deal is coming at a 45 drink a
few beers that's right [__]
it's Tuesday night my lips are purple
and I didn't blow [__] Barney won't
be giving the office [__] it don't stop
and who said bong Italy ready for bong
him sure why not
it's that type of party thing we got put
this [__] jam over yeah it is in full
effect
[Music]
which one of those guys good any that
that virgin nearly to wax costume
you have one waxy stuff
I should take a picture that I'm tell
Phoebe you came all over the table
and they'll put in the same as I love
you [__] looking leak came all over the
table and it's blue something's going on
[Music]
people a lot of [__] happens in behind
the scenes that you don't even [__]
know by now if you eat that waxy scarlet
and sit on the little [__]
we got a scrape that off of like that
anyway who gives a [__] about that it's
time [__] oh [__] you're like Joey
what's insightful fun hit time
[__] then we'll get this
podcast started I almost lost [__] but
you know me I got reflexes like a
[__] cat you understand me that's
what happens when you hang out with cats
all [__] day speaking of which I
gotta take Demi for the doctor next week
yeah no man I can't forget gold but not
young [__] Buffalo you gotta check
him up the target time
Harry's got a black girl on his lip I
can't who gets a [__] black as my dad
has a black on his lips he won't let me
touch it yeah I had him in a headlock
trying to [__] get it with a black
he's eaten on hissing because he's got
the heart of gold that poor cat Harry's
got a heart of gold
we're fitting this Jimmy gets pissed
I'll spray that [__] [__] this
at me
[Music]
oh [__]
this one's going to rock your world Lee
this is a real [__] Puerto Rican
hamburger yeah oh yeah
and then I'm gonna let the joint flow
down for like a half we're gonna open
that rip that up and put the guts in a
bottle and see where that case you're
gonna hear voices for three days in this
family Chinese a little [__] focus
this is a coupon hit situation the first
one's gonna heat it the second one's
gonna hack the vein I'd take tails to it
the second was the main one okay this is
the main the breathing exercises
look up to get the head blood to the
back of the neck attack
[Music]
that's the one that killed more mommy
oh my [__] or do I know my [__] you
think I'm here to [__] make a [__]
get out I studied in India with the top
[__] bong people with Maharaja I
smoked pot with the [__] Hindu that
pork John Lennon how to do [__] bong
it so when it comes to smoking bonnets
don't [__] anyway I'm doing this bong it
University next summer a three week
training course three weeks because
listen it takes three weeks for me to
get it take six weeks for you to get
acclimated to hang out - do you want to
run what uncle Joey's gonna take you
three weeks you gotta pay for your
lodging the whole thing and this
training is from 9:00 to 11:00 and then
you come back after your nap for the
hospital stay and about do it for every
day all right here we go leaving again
back let the blood hit the franklin
raines
think about we about to do attack
[Music]
what's this to do my own Discovery
Channel I can tell you what happens ten
seconds after you blow this [__] already
I can do I can tell you the whole [__]
this man
[Music]
though I smoked with Hindus I smoked
with people in Switzerland listen all
the top bonded people I've had
conferences which I'm not like a bunch
of white people well I think nah
underground
nobody knows nothing you show up at
somebody's house they got ten bong it so
everybody [__] smokes till they pass
out and next morning you wake up and you
got monkeys playing [__] and a couple of
light roads on your forehead I've been
there I've been there with a white
jacket I've been that [__] you
ready Adam ready let's do this [__]
ain't got time to [__] around alright
look at poor Louise over there thinking
he's got to find another [__] zip
recruit against it's killing them
remember look back let the blood hit
concentrate on what you're about to do
breathe out in your stomach a few times
now attack like a [__] marine there
you go the first one's gonna be [__]
candy stuff then the second one oh [__]
look at him he's on fire is what I'm
talking about
watch there you go now he's focused and
look at that that's a beautiful smooth
sea it spans in the Hat the hash bullet
I weed the [__] I used to get some
Frankie Porto Rican all that [__]
expands in your lungs after you letter
that you wanna water
maker's mark holding some of that then
[__] get the cup for yourself what to me
there's coke but we always buy something
in toxins the [__] blows that comes over
you yeah you're good looks like this is
it
salud I say say it the [__] the
holiday season Mazel Tov yeah
[__] you got a Mazel Tov these
are the [__] [__] even doing
Rami listen I'm saying yeah I'm CUBAN
I'm the wrong [__] tried me I just
grew up with your Ilsa
I grew up with old-school Jews in Jersey
which taught me the ropes Tansley ones
that lifeline is this [__] oh my god
they're the [__] crazy
no they don't be except that pistol they
got we're bulletproof vest er people do
the Scientology show all they need is me
talk tell them the secret to the Jersey
Jews and how they [__] [__]
savages no no I think it's part of the
other thing pray go [__] yourself
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz give us
10 minutes and we'll get this [__]
party started I want to thank Adam ray
and we say at my main man and that's it
that's how we do it he on a Tuesday
night can you imagine when Friday would
be anyway give me 10 minutes and we'll
do this right